patricia de naissance du syndicat
national des personnels titulaires et
contractuels de l'enseignement supérieur
le snpes est avec nous bonjour madame de
la sienne mangez vous êtes professeur
des universités ici sur le campus de
schoelcher il faut le reconnaître c'est
une véritable ambiance délétère qui
règne sur le campus
notre syndicat depuis quelques jours bon
au créneau pour dénoncer un état
d'esprit qui peut nous être fatal oui
c'est vrai c'est il y a un certain
nombre d'années maintenant que s'étant
bien s'est installée elle a cru elle
s'est développée de plus en plus et
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile nous avons un certain nombre
de personnels aussi bien
enseignants-chercheurs administratifs
qui sont en grande souffrance et les
étudiants sont en souffrance aussi parce
que l'ambiance est vraiment une ambiance
conflictuelle est assez insupportable
vous avez parlé de ces sionistes la
semaine dernière sur 12 en tenue qui
sont ceux ci sioniste alors la ligne du
syndicat est de ne pas dire de nom mais
il ya un petit groupe de personnes âgées
quantifier précisément en martinique
d'après nous ils sont 16 mai en a aussi
quelques heures en guadeloupe qui met en
avant une division entre la martinique
et la guadeloupe c'est à dire qui c'est
part d'un autre université des antilles
en deux petites universelle qui serait
l'intérêt pour ces six sioniste qui
serait sain selon vous a bien qu'on se
retrouve avec une université qui
accueillerait même pas 3000 étudiants
très sincèrement je ne sais pas parce
que pour moi il n'y a aucun intérêt à
vouloir cela est ce que c'est ce sont
des velléités de pouvoir d'installer
vraiment mais je ne sais pas très
sincèrement je ne sais pas il sait si
sony s'ils le sont au sens c'est qu'au
sein de l'université
il ya aussi des personnes extérieures de
comprendre que certains politiques s'il
reste certaines ficelles pour aller dans
ce sens alors il y en a sans doute
puisqu'il ya eu des déclarations qui ont
été faites à la ctm et certains élus
avaient effectivement demandé une
création d'une université de la
martinique
alors je dois à dire là devant tout le
monde
grand public devant l'antenne que
j'incrimine et à ton monsieur nylon
monsieur jean-philippe nylon donc je
présente mes excuses publiques à
monsieur le député jean philippe mille
euros puisque j'ai dit qu'il était de
ces personnes et nous avons eu une
longue conversation très cordiale
d'ailleurs il est très fructueuse et
qu'il sort de deux très positif de cela
c'est que monsieur le député
jean-philippe ni l'homme a affirmé edi a
plusieurs fois pendant cet entretien
qu'il était pour l'université des
antilles et qu'il n'avait jamais été
pour la création d'une université de la
martinique d'ailleurs que des la
séparation de la guyane is it est
prononcée très fortement contre cet
éclatement alors patricia donatien ce
que le salut de cette université
actuellement des antilles puisqu'elle a
été université des antilles de la guyane
jusqu'en 2015 est ce que le salut de
cette université passe par une
intervention des politiques des
parlementaires plus précisément oui je
pense un puisque il faut que l'ensemble
c'est pour ça que j'avais appelé à à une
espèce de confédération de rassemblement
de tout le monde
oui c'est ça le problème n'en eut pas à
l'eau il faudrait qu'il soit en
martinique ou en guadeloupe n'arrive pas
à faire face ils n'arrivent pas à faire
face parce que il s'agit véritablement
ce que je voudrais dire enfin je fais je
finis d'abord ma première phrase c'est
qu'il faudrait effectivement que les
parlementaires les élus et toutes les
personnalités qu'on qui ont dû point
signifie très clairement gouvernement
français qu'on ne veut pas de la
scission est que notre salut va dans une
université des antilles faute
alors pour ce qui est du reste c'est
vrai que il y a une très grande
difficultés à fonctionner mais ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que ce n'est
pas général il s'agit vraiment de
conflits de personnes donc nous avons
travaillé pendant très longtemps on
pendant plus d'une d'une trentaine
d'années puisque lui âgé a été créée en
1980 du très bien avec la guadeloupe
nous continuons à fonctionner beaucoup
de personnel a continué à fonctionner
très très bien avec le personnel de la
guadeloupe il n'y a pas de raison que ça
ne continue pas de noyau qui fout la
merde tout simplement oui voilà et qui
va très souvent pas loin ghazi un
problème de communication sans doute
parce que ces personnes sont très
souvent devant la pressé comme unique
cède 7 internationaux notion vous avez
dit que cette situation perdure depuis
plusieurs années pourquoi votre syndicat
national des personnels titulaires et
contractuels de l'enseignement supérieur
ne montent au créneau que maintenant
parce que nous avons toujours respecté
l'éthique et le droit des risées have
normalement observé un silence qui a
mené aussi à cette situation n'aurait pu
monter au créneau beaucoup plus tôt
c'est vrai c'est vrai nous sommes montés
au créneau de manière interne et nous
avons fait des communiqués que nous
avons d'ailleurs envoyé à la presse pour
dire de manière très claire que nous
allions communiquer sur le main non
c'est n'est pas cela mais vraiment je
tiens à insister sur le fait qu' il y a
comment vous dire lorsqu il y à un
conflit au sein d'universités et ça ce
n'est pas une chose rare ça arrive tout
le temps et partout dans les universités
françaises
comment s'assurer que normalement
s'assurer que l'on et yonne parce que
jamais problématiques et aux élèves
d'une personne ou qui aux élèves de
petit groupe de personne ne crie au
secours du laboratoire indien savoir qui
venu ternir l'image douala ne doit
étonner au la totalité de l'institution
n'ont pas quand même de plusieurs vies
de plusieurs millions d'euros de
détourner il fallait bien que ça explose
moment ou un autre dans une absolue
absolument ça ça on s'appelait les
politiques pouvaient être associés mais
ça aurait dû être réglée au sein du
ministère
il n'était pas nécessaire que lui âgé
dans son ensemble soit sacrifiée pour
régler un problème de ce type alors il y
a une mission de médiation venu cette
semaine après tapis très à fort de
france que pouvons nous attendre de ceux
du rapport qui sera transmis au
ministère enfin nous espérons déjà à nou
s intéresserait fortement que ne sera
pas au centre que il est indispensable
que l'université des antilles perdure
que cette université n'éclate pas parce
que si elle éclate nous allons nous
retrouver avec de toutes petites
universités qui ne seront pas viable qui
ne pourront pas payer d'impôts au pape
audio de la recherche qui ne pourront
pas produits audi des formations
intéressantes
j'ai entendu votre collecte ou taleo 10
ans que les patrons martiniquais se
plaignait que les population
martiniquaise ne soit pas bien formés
c'est là qu'il faut aller il faut former
la jeunesse il faut former les étudiants
pour que c'est cette jeunesse puisse
répondre aux besoins du tissu socio
économique
alors cette mission pour lui a remis ce
sont plutôt ses listes d'étudiants il
qui s'appelle en sommes ensemble pour
l'intérêt étudiants a remis une petite
note d'une dizaine de pages à 7 à cette
mission de médiation
tout y passe l'ancienne gouvernance
l'actuelle gouvernance montrer du droit
manque de respect de fair-play des
dénonciations publiques non confirmées
des diffusion de fausses nouvelles
des blocages de sites avec des personnes
extérieures le relationnel plutôt
délicat entre la présidence de
l'université actuellement apprête à
quitter la vice présidence du pôle
martinique les syndicats n'avaient pas
besoin d'attendre une médiation d'une
mission de médiation pour montrer pour
dire tout ce qui va pas sur le campus
alors je n'ai pas lu ce texte je n'ai
pas lu ce texte mais je suppose que les
étudiants on en a vraiment assez qu'ils
ont dû être et cash dit ce qu'ils
avaient à dire bon c'est le rôle aussi
oui et lorsqu'on se promène sur le
campus de chercheurs on entend quand
même un certain nombre de choses
l'impact de ce dossier cérémonial et
conflits entre les personnes entre les
deux îles
la pâte l'affluence est pas comment dire
de réseaux mystico philosophique aux
religions parlent même de magico
religieux non il s'agit d'élections au
niveau des étudiants
c'est un véritable foutoir oui c'est
vraiment très dommage quoi que ce soit
cette image là que nous ayons est que ce
soit cette ambiance-là qui prévalent
plutôt qu'une ambiance de travail une
ambiance conviviale
normalement nous devons
formée cette jeunesse dans dans une
bonne ambiance et surtout mettre en
avant des valeurs beaucoup plus
intéressante que celle que vous venez
dénoncé comme an plus tôt sous sauver le
soldat campus ben j'espère en se
mobilisant et en travaillant moi je
crois que moi je crois beaucoup au
travail
c'est une de mes valeurs moi je suis
vous est demandé à mes étudiants ils
disent que même d'une assiette c'est une
véritable terroriste en ce sens il faut
vraiment travailler c'est à dire qu'on
ne peut pas arriver là devant la
ministre devant des parlementaires sans
avoir dit projet clair sans avoir d'idée
voilà d'une dynamique de travail qu'ils
soient mises en place donc aux c'est
d'un autre syndicat nous avons des
projets nous avons commencé depuis fort
longtemps d'ailleurs un aa réfléchir sur
un certain nombre de questions sur les
nécessités de formation sur l'adéquation
entre l'environnement de nous dit deux
îles et les formations sur l'ouverture
sur la caraïbe la coopération notamment
avec louis university of the west indies
et les autres universités de la caraïbe
et sur des rites ablement comment
redonner une image forte à travers des
actions que le renouvellement de la
gouvernance actuelle à des personnes de
la gouvernance je pense qu'on n'a pas le
choix merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nos patricia donatien merci on rappelle
que vous êtes représentant du syndicat
national des personnels titulaires et
contractuels de l'enseignement supérieur
et qu'il était question de l'ambiance
qui règne sur le campus de chercher à se
donner bonne journée